the omicron variant is in europe and
with every passing hour more cases are
detected with the single largest number
of infections found on two flights that
arrived here at amsterdam
airport on friday from cape town and
johannesburg of the 624 passengers on
board
61 tested positive for covert 19 and
more than a dozen have the omicron
variant
all are now isolating
100
100 of the people who return from
southern africa will be contacted we
also ask the municipalities to visit 100
of the people at home to check whether
they are really isolating
the omicron variants now being
identified in germany italy the uk
denmark belgium czech republic and
austria with cases likely to be
circulating in france according to the
french government
the urgent message from brussels
couldn't be any clearer vaccinate
vaccinate vaccinate boost boost boost as
much as is possible
because this boosting or vaccination
raises the level of antibodies and
stimulates the memory cells
for covet viruses therefore this is the
police of the immune system the
europe-wide response has been to
restrict flights from several southern
african countries and introduce
mandatory testing of people arriving
from abroad
travelers coming here to the uk will
have to quarantine for 10 days at their
own expense moves some scientists
believe won't be effective in stopping
the spread
it's completely naive to imagine that
we're going to be able to prevent the
dispersion of the reagent this is
already the case as an example in
belgium we had the traveller in belgium
that ended up with a vadant had
absolutely no direct contact with anyone
from southern africa
scientists in italy have produced the
first image of the variant that has more
mutations in spike proteins the parts
that interact with human cells compared
with the highly infectious delta variant
in the absence of any hard data on how
widespread or virulent the omicron
variant is or indeed any information on
whether or not existing vaccines confer
a degree of immunity against it
scientists are urging caution do too
much by way of new restrictions and it
could have a negative impact on europe's
economies do too little and it could
take the pandemic in a dangerous new
direction
neave barker al jazeera london